it's another day at work for Tiffany
Neumann and that means another wedding
today she's invited us to come along
she's presided over 1500 weddings over
the years same-sex couples from all over
America come to her and Washington's
liberal laws to read their vows but even
today she still finds some people
disapprove I've had a few that have
voiced it some that have told me their
concern for what I've been doing to
society and/or my soul and I've told
them you know thank you for the concern
I appreciate it but there are no such
concerns as we arrived just outside
Washington in suburban Virginia at the
home of the happy couple
here the ban on same-sex marriage was
only lifted last October
chris decided there's no time to lose so
after 12 years together he and his
partner Adam a tying the knot you have
chosen this special time in place to be
married to one another as Tiffany
performs her role reading the vows
the couple's minds are also on the
Supreme Court as an activist and a
lawyer working in gay rights it's a
course they fought for it's nice to know
that whether we win or whether we lose
in court we have this board of our
friends and families and that's the most
important thing these kids and support
is there from both sides of the family
there's a lot of traditional marriages
that don't even last one or two years
and here they've been together for 12
years and we know they're gonna be
together for a long long time well so
we're very very happy for him as the
guests mingle outside the party tiffany
takes a moment to reflect on why she
aligned herself with this cause love is
love and it's hard enough to find
someone that's going to accept you in
your entirety and is going to then give
themselves in return to you and in the
very end of it all is just going to be
there that's the promise Adam and Chris
have now made
their family say that the Supreme Court
should let couples like them do the same
all across America them to do it to sign
it let it happen why not you you know
you everybody needs to be a love-in you
you can't choose who you fall in love
with few of the people enjoying
themselves here today would disagree
with that but as Tiffany ends another
day's work is a bittersweet thought for
her if same-sex marriage does go
nationwide fewer and fewer couples will
need to come to Washington for her
services this year she says there's
going to be time to find a new job